buzzwords like bitcoin cryptocurrency
nft and the metaverse are becoming part
of everyday vocabulary and everyone from
major corporations to entrepreneurs to
the general public is starting to take
notice non-fungible tokens which are a
one-of-a-kind blockchain asset often
connected to a form of digital art have
particularly exploded over the past year
nft sales reached 24.9 billion dollars
in 2021 up from 94.9 million in 2020
according to dap radar nfts are
infiltrating every industry from art to
music to real estate it was only a
matter of time before they broke into
the food and hospitality sector in
december 2021 celebrity chef tom
colecchio announced on twitter that he
was entering the nft space with top chef
spike mendelson they released 8 888
pizza themed nfts called chefty pizzas
valued at around 200 each
some restaurants are taking the concept
one step further offering token holders
exclusive memberships and perks as part
of their nft ownership in 2021
entrepreneurs david rodelitz gary
vaynerchuk and chef josh capen announced
their venture fly fish club dubbed the
world's first ever nft restaurant a fly
fish club nft grants the owner unlimited
access to a members only private dining
venue in new york city along with a
series of exclusive digital and
in-person special events
even though the exact location of the
club which is slated to open sometime in
2023 is still to be determined all 1500
nfts released to the public sold out in
minutes
initial prices for the nfts range from
around eight thousand dollars in the
basic tier to fourteen thousand dollars
for the premier tier though their recent
resale values are going for nearly
double those amounts
there's also an nft with perks at a
restaurant that is already open for
business chotomate the pioneering global
nikkei dining destination with locations
in london toronto and miami beach
recently announced it would release its
first nft in april dubbed the founder
the nft will be a one-time release
collectible chip card that grants its
owner exclusive membership access with
an array of benefits redeemable all over
the world
perks include invitations to every
chotomate restaurant opening around the
world plus first class flights and
five-star accommodations an annual
distillery vineyard and premium farm
visit new year's eve dinner invitation
for six at any chotamate location an
exclusive at-home experience with the
restaurant's executive chef two tickets
to one major sports event a year and
more
there will only be one founder nft
produced and it is currently the only
chotamate membership available adding to
its exclusivity the founder nft will be
available for purchase on openc for 1
million
there will be a launch event at its
miami beach location on april 5th during
miami nft week and the bitcoin 2020
miami beach conference which are
expected to welcome thousands of crypto
enthusiasts from all over the world
back in new york city the popular
brooklyn chop house from restauranteurs
robert dompu cummins and stratus
morphigan is also getting into the
crypto game this month the steakhouse
opened its highly anticipated five-story
25 000 square foot times square location
the space includes an intimate seller
area that starting in early fall will be
only accessible to guests who have
purchased the special nft membership
according to the new york post the
starting price for the basic membership
is around eight thousand dollars though
more expensive tiers which range from
twenty thousand to one million will open
up even more exclusive perks as the
popularity of cryptocurrency in the
metaverse continues to grow we're bound
to see more chefs and restaurants get a
taste for the nft space the only
question remains are the rest of us
willing to take a bite
[Music]